so what do you think about this the
rapid development of LMS if you could
just like stick on that it's still
incredibly impressive like with Chad GPT
just even tragedy what are your thoughts
about uh reinforcement learning with
human feedback on these large language
models
to go back to when calculators first
came out and or computers and like I
wasn't around look I'm 33 years old and
to like see how that affected
like Society maybe you're right so I
want to put on the
the uh the big picture hat here oh my
God they refrigerator wow the
refrigerator electricity all that kind
of stuff
but
you know with the internet
large language models seeming human-like
basically passing a touring test
it seems it might have really at scale
rapid transformative effects on society
but you're saying like other
technologies have as well
so maybe calculator is not the best
example that because that just seems
like
um well no maybe calculator a poor Milk
Man the day he learned about
refrigerators he's like I'm done
you tell me you can just keep the milk
in your house you don't need me to
deliver it every day I'm done well yeah
you have to actually look at the
Practical impacts of certain
technologies that they've had
yeah probably electricity is a big one
and also how rapidly it spread
man the internet is a big one I do think
it's different this time though
yeah it just feels like structure's
getting smaller
the initiative humans
that makes humans special
it feels like it's getting smaller
rapidly though doesn't it or is that
just a feeling we dramatize everything I
think we dramatized everything I think
that that you ask the Milkman when he
saw refrigerators and they're gonna have
one of these in every home
hahaha
yeah yeah yeah
yeah maybe but boys are impressive
so much more impressive than seeing uh a
Chess World Champion AI system I
disagree actually I disagree
I think things like mu zero and alphago
are so much more impressive because
these things are playing beyond the
highest human level
the language models are writing Middle
School level essays and people are like
wow it's a great essay it's a great five
paragraph essay about the causes of the
Civil War okay forget the Civil War just
generating code codex
you're saying it's mediocre code
terrible but I don't think it's terrible
I think it's just mediocre code yeah
often
close to correct
like for mediocre just the scariest kind
of code I spent five percent of time
typing and 95 percent of time debugging
the last thing I want is close to
correct code I want a machine that can
help me with the debugging not with the
typing you know it's like L2 level two
uh uh driving similar kind of thing yeah
it's you still should be a good
programmer in order to modify I wouldn't
even say debugging it's just modifying
the code reading it don't think it's
like level two driving
I think driving is not tool complete and
programming is meaning you don't use
like the best possible tools to drive
right you're not you're not like like
cars have basically the same interface
for the last 50 years yep computers have
a radically different interface okay can
you describe the concept of tool
complete so think about the difference
between a car from 1980 and a car from
today yeah no difference really it's got
a bunch of pedals it's got a steering
wheel
great maybe now it has a few Adas
features but it's pretty much the same
car right you have no problem getting
into a 1980 car and driving it
take programmer today who spent their
whole life doing JavaScript and you put
them in an apple 2E prompt and you tell
them about the line numbers in basic
but how do I insert something between
lines 17 and 18. oh wow
uh but the so you in tool you're putting
in the programming languages so just the
entirety stack of the tooling exactly so
it's not just like the like IDs or
something like this it's uh everything
yes it's ide's the language is the
runtimes it's it's everything in
programming is is tool complete so like
almost if
if if if codex or or co-pilot are
helping you
it probably means that your framework or
library is bad and there's too much
boilerplate in it
yeah but don't you think so much
programming has boilerplate tiny grad is
now 2700 lines and it can run llama and
stable diffusion and all of this stuff
is in 2700 lines boilerplate and
abstraction in directions and all these
things are just bad code
well
let's talk about good code and bad code
there's a I would say I don't know for
generic scripts that I write just
offhand like I like 80 of it is written
by GPT just like quick quick like
offhand stuff so not like libraries not
like performing code not stuff for
Robotics and so on just quick stuff
because your basic so much of
programming is doing some
some yeah boilerplate but to do so
efficiently and quickly
because you can't really automate it
fully with like generic method like a
generic kind of
um ID type of recommendation or
something like this you do need to have
some of the complexity of language
models
if I was really writing like maybe today
if I wrote like a lot of like data
parsing stuff yeah I mean I don't play
ctfs anymore but if I still play ctfs a
lot of like it's just like you have to
write like a par server for this data
format like I wonder or like admin of
code
um I wonder when the models are going to
start to help with that kind of code and
they may they may and the models Also
may help you with speed yeah the model
is very fast
but where the models won't I my
programming speed is not at all limited
by my typing speed
and in very few cases it is yes if I'm
writing some script to just like parse
some weird data format sure my
programming speed is limited by my
typing speeds what about looking stuff
up because that's essentially a more
efficient lookup right you know
when I was out when I was at Twitter I
tried to use uh chatgpt to uh to like
ask some questions like what's the API
for this and it would just hallucinate
it would just give me completely made up
API functions that sounded real
uh what do you think that's just a
temporary kind of stage
you don't think you'll get better and
better and better in this kind of stuff
because like it only hallucinates stuff
in in the edge cases yes if your
engineering code it's actually pretty
good yes if you are writing an absolute
basic like react app with a button if
you're gonna hallucinate sure no there's
kind of ways to fix the hallucination
problem I think Facebook is an
interesting paper it's called Atlas and
it's actually weird the way that we do
uh language models right now are all of
the uh information is in the weight and
the human brains don't really like this
with like a hippocampus and a memory
system so why don't llms have a memory
system and there's people working on
them I think future llms are going to be
like smaller but are going to run
looping on themselves and are going to
have retrieval systems
and the thing about using a retrieval
system is you can cite sources
explicitly um
which is uh really helpful to integrate
the human into the loop of the of the
thing because you can go check the
sources and you can investigate so
whenever the thing is hallucinating you
can like have the human supervision so
that's pushing it towards level two kind
of that's going to kill Google
wait which part when someone makes an
llm that's capable of citing its sources
it will kill Google
LM that's citing a sources because
that's basically a search engine
that's what people want in the search
engine but also Google might be the
people that build it maybe
I'll put ads on it